many republicans have criticized the fbi
for investigating the former president
and some have even shown sympathy for
the january sixth rioters who attacked
police all that has given president
biden an opening on the campaign trail
yesterday he used a speech in
pennsylvania to try to position the
democrats as the party that is toughest
on crime ed o'keefe has more
on the airwaves in states like
pennsylvania john fetterman wants to
release convicted murderers from prison
public safety is why i ran for office
and now on the stump i'm opposed to
defunding the police i'm also opposed to
defunding the fbi how to fight crime and
gun violence are taking center stage
during a stop in pennsylvania tuesday
president biden attacked those
republicans who've called for defunding
the fbi in response to its search of
former president donald trump's home in
florida
and denounced republicans who defend
rioters at the u.s capitol on january 6.
you can't be pro-law enforcement and
pro-insurrection
you can't be a party of law and order
and call the people who attacked the
police on january 6 patriots
the increased focus on law enforcement
crime and guns on both sides of the
aisle comes as the majority of likely
voters see crime and guns as very
important issues after the economy and
inflation and while some gop officials
say they want to defund the fbi
most rank and file republicans don't
back the idea nearly half of registered
voters overall say they'd be less likely
to vote for a candidate who supports
that position i'm sure he's going to
spend more money that we don't have but
republicans like wisconsin senator ron
johnson doubt the president's calls for
more police funding democrats are very
good at providing
a
title on a bill
that
promises many things but they just never
deliver on it
now president biden returns to
pennsylvania tomorrow night to
philadelphia to give a speech on what he
likes to call the ongoing battle over
the soul of the nation and voters in
northeast pennsylvania are getting a
visit from former president trump when
he campaigns with republican candidates
on saturday night pennsylvania's getting
all the attention this week eureka
they'll get to the other states before
election yeah
very important state ed thank you